hello the appointment in montreal I
finally my wife and I are
available on the evening of the 17th on Wednesday of
the coming week
and if you are interested indicate that here
and then if you have any suggestions on the
way which is not at ake  where we eat
very low please let us know and
then even if we are not very very
many it will be very interesting to
meet you but quickly shouting
the certif
only the cross that this time in the evening
the place it remains to be decided
and  then i will have you aimed here
so if you are interested say it
here the price stalin would have seen between ceng
to lady gaga and mariah years of servitude
his mark my hand soraya strokes of a
blow thank you see you soon